[Music]
hi everyone
my grandmaster dennis borsch and
this is insane in the end game so today
i'm going to take a look
at a couple of recent games from
the euro rapid tournament
featuring magnus carlsen nakamura and
all
the big elite players now dobo has been
really showing off his skills and
actually managed to
qualify to the playoffs
and it actually has to do with a couple
of games that has been played
in the preliminaries so i am going to
focus just a little bit on
the game's plate um
just a second here
so this game that i want to start with
first is
shankland and dubov which actually been
very interesting
from the opening d4 d5 c4
e5 and in fact this is very surprising
because it is very very rare to see the
alban counter gambit
ever show up on the highest of levels
and what makes this extremely special
the d takes
e5 instead of d4
do both plays my move knight e7
which i actually played a couple times
online already which in the databases 97
is actually an interesting idea
trying to keep detention and this kind
of put shankland
in a difficult position where he had to
defend a position
which is very unfamiliar to him and it
is sort of a new concept
not very well known at all there has
been only a handful of games
knight f3 knight c6 knight d2
dtx c4 e3 knight g6
playing typical alban style but
we are not going to focus too much on
the middle game but on the end game part
queen a4
trying to press bishop d7
e6 takes bishop takes take stakes
should be seven castle castle queen b5
rook b8 knight e4 queen d7
bishop d2 knight ce5 and we can
state that at this moment the position
is roughly
even nobody really has better chances
both black and white are felt developed
however there are some little details
that you have to notice and that is
that there is some asymmetrical play on
both sides what has an advantage
of four versus three while black has the
advantage
of three versus two on the queen side
it takes d7 knight takes d7
rook c1 and this is actually critical
moment number one what are you going to
do
are you just going to be very passive
but
solid as black or be more ambitious
but whenever you kind of look at a do
buff game you know the answer
it never is solid and passive so it goes
for c5
and c5 is sort of signaling to shankland
that he
is clearly aiming to mobilize those
pawns and roll it down with b5 and c4
now it won't be an easy task white of
course has b3
and some of those pieces
for black are a little bit loose not as
much on e7 but the knight on d7 is
actually a little bit undefended
rook have d1 rook fd8 therefore
do above over defends it and then
prepares the idea
bishop c3 and again we get into these
typical positions
where b5 of course is going to be
an idea but here dubos realizes that
okay these pieces are not
too well placed but you can't really
improve them right now
shanklin's pieces kind of takes away
all the best squares so he goes on
to activate some other pieces
and here he goes for this maneuver of
knight f8
knight e6 and because
of the close nature of the position
which i could really call
semi closed duval has the time to
activate that knight
knight f8 king f1
knight e6 over defending almost triple
defending
the c5 palm
and you can already visit visibly see
that black is doing much better than a
couple of moves before this knight is
actually participating in the action
b3 now this bishop looks annoying
sudubov goes f6 just reducing the scope
of that bishop
king e2 king f7 g4
now shankland has been surprised in the
opening but
he's still doing a good job playing the
right side
of this end game he's maybe
not better but he is trying to fix a dub
of structure and he's not letting
him go f5 and g6 putting all those pawns
on the white squares
which is typical in these type of end
games if
you can if you have a dark squared
bishop you should post
and put your pawns on the other color
that is white squares
but shankland does not allow that in
fact
make sure that two above species
stand passive knight b6
aiming to get this knight to d5
chase the bishop away and also kind of
centralizing the knight bishop a5
and bishop a5 in some ways does feel a
little bit
reactionary not necessarily a bad move
but it doesn't really have
a constructive idea behind it apart from
sort of trying to hinder
duboff's plan something like knight d2
knight c4
might be a little bit better instead of
bishop a5 as bishop a5
is a little bit putting a bishop on the
sides
ship a5 who takes d1 book takes d1
although dubo's next move is somewhat
surprising and
if you're used to principal chess this
move
might catch you unawares and probably
did catch
sam shankland unawares here as well so
i'm gonna
leave you guys a little bit of time to
figure out
what move adobov played here
you would think that black would play
something like rook c8
takes takes a4 and then
shanklin would be correct they're just
too many wide square weaknesses this
bishop
is pretty bad and an eventual knight f
d2 knight c4
might lead to a big big advantage
for white however this is by no means
forced for black and he does the most
unconventional move you can possibly
find here and that is knight eight eight
this is not something the doctor ever
prescribes
you to do you shouldn't put your knot on
the rim
and on a8 however
after h4 and b6 this knight will make a
slight
return to the game and
white really doesn't have any ways of
punishing that
note rook d7 would be countered by
king e8 smoking out that rook if you go
back
just b6 knight c7
and the rook d to king e8 inclusion
doesn't make any big differences here
it's h4 b6 bishop c3
rook d8 so now with the pawn already
moved to b6
for example rook c8 rook d7 could be
annoying
so do above circumvents that with rook
d8
rook takes the 8 9 takes d8
g5 and g5 is an ambitious move
which by in itself is not a bad thing
being ambitious
but g5 does create some weaknesses on h4
if for example
white goes something like h5
there is still a very good blockade
and sort of taking away those important
squares on g6 and f5
so why it probably isn't worse at all g5
is ambitious though
um shem shankland is trying to press
on the f pawn and create uh juicy
outpost
on f5 knight e6
gtx gtx knight g3
so white is pushing here and tries to
kind of
claim on f5 and pushing
black back but this does give
ample chances for duboff to win and as
you will see
it does happen so again with every
position like this
you have to figure out which piece of
yours is completely out of play
and i mean it is fairly obvious it's not
on a8
so it's coming back into the game with
knight c7
at f5 and id5
so clearly here dubo
isn't crying bitter tears for that
bishop he is much too happy to give it
away
and in that case he would have two
amazing knights versus
a somewhat blocked bishop which is sort
of staring at the wall of that pawn on
f6
which is very hard to remove and then
black does have this easy plan of b5 and
c4
and that probably is just much more
comfortable for black
winning i'm not sure but easier to play
with black
that is out of question that is of
course the case
bishop d2 of course retaining the bishop
not taking this one
and these are those
ridiculously underestimated moves
bishop f8 i've seen this one and i think
if you've seen my previous since in the
end game you've seen the reity game
where reity played bishop d8 bishop b6
activating a bishop that was supposed to
be quite
bad this move by duba sort of resonates
in that same direction
he moves that bishop away and says yes
this might not worth a lot
but this bishop might prove useful later
in the game
supporting the c5 pawn or after the
eventual b5 c4 break
so a4 a6 rolling it up
bringing those pawns into the game
creating a passer
and with every end game one of the most
important things
is to create a pass pawn king d3
b5 it takes it takes
now still if you'd ask me
is there a guarantee anyone's going to
lose this game
i wouldn't say so the game is still
roughly even
but with black having more and more
chances
with having two versus one on the queen
side
while white really didn't have a chance
to create a pass pawn of his own
bishop a5 this bishop keeps returning to
a5
sort of taking away and restricting
black's pieces but
it still just doesn't strike as the most
accurate
knight g7 takes
takes h5 a nice little move kind of
getting closer to the all
powerful h8 square and also sort of
fixing the pawn on h7
king e6 bishop d2
bishop h6 again notice
that dubois does everything in his power
to activate his bishop
knight h4 bishop g5 knight g2
f5 and you can already see that this is
a great success
this is a great success for black
because this bishop that was sort of cut
off
now actually is dominating that knight
on g2
it's dominating that knight and now it's
clear that it is black who has
the better chances f4 bishop e7
and now knight f6 knight e4 does look
quite
threatening and that pawn that looked
quite nice on h5
actually becomes a target so
because of sham shanklin's hesitant play
now duboff have has clear winning
chances in this position
e4 take 6 knight f6
here knight takes h5
but there is another thing that we've
got to talk about
and that is the reduced material so if
sam shanklin manages to exchange off
those pawns off the board and keep a
piece he
will probably have a theoretical draw
however those pawns are on the two
sides of the board which usually favors
the one
with those two pawns and
it is actually not that easy to defend
because white has to be very accurate
when to and how to sacrifice
93 knight f6 so first thing first
dubo makes sure that all of his pawns
are defended
and then he looks for plants he's not
rushing
any palm moves till that f5
king d6 going over to help out those
cmb pawns should be one
knight d5 ship g3
king c6 king is moving over
c4 actually is becoming a big threat of
course
it doesn't make any sense for shankland
to exchange
because of the aforementioned two
pawns rolling on the h-valency file
so naturally goes knight g4 ship d6
so we're just going to see a couple of
moves where shankland avoids exchanges
and do both offers it again and again
bishop h4 and now as these guys
and pieces got a little bit
discoordinated he goes h5
you can only attack it with knight f6
but that would
lead to further simplifications and with
the king being awfully close to
f7 that doesn't look too threatening for
black
not f2 bishop e5 again notice
how much do above centralizes his pieces
knight e4 knight b6
f6 knight d7 still
that square is under control so even
though this
looks visually appealing it does
not amount to a whole lot f7
king d5 bringing the king bishop g3
bishop g7 duba is being extremely
careful
and he is very cognizant of the fact
that this game
is very important he needs to win this
in order to have
a chance to qualify knight d6
king c6 over defending king e4
h4 little tactical tricks you can't take
because king takes d6
and now you actually can see that
white hinges on a little bit like if the
f1 is lost it's game over
bishop h2 we should have fade just
chasing the knight away
h3 now you can't really win the h1
without
reorganizing your pieces but it might
take just too much time
bishop g3 b4 therefore dubof
sort of prepares for the advance on the
other side so
when shanklin takes the pawn he already
has a passer
going on the c or b file
you have three king d5 king g4
check again every exchange is in favor
of black king takes knight takes f7
check king d4 and the other thing that i
didn't actually
mention as might took time to take that
palm with the king
there's a king missing on this side so
virtually black is up a king plus a pawn
on this side of the board knight c4
king c3 knight a5 bishop d6
and with this king being so far away
again this is just completely winning if
you take
take here
black can just go knight b5 knight d4
and knight takes b3 and it's just
completely
winning or the simple c4 both cases
it is just easily winning for black
bishop f2
knight e5 king c2 bishop c7
c4 and even though the material is
reduced you just really don't have
enough time
to stop the b pump from promoting so
quite a spectacular game by dubov
even though the middle game slash end
game was roughly even
he did take his little moments and
chances
to outplay shankland which is actually
very important for him
to qualify for the playoffs where he got
in
so this was the shankling game i wanted
to show and i
do want to show the other game he played
against
dominguez so this game
against dominguez again
this is a must-win scenario so he plays
another
funky opening not quite the
gambit that i came up with with knight
e7
but a bit more of an adventurous version
of the dragon
d6 this is the rouser
and everybody and their friends play e6
here
but duboff is known to be very inventive
and he goes up with the idea of g6
he's saying i am willing to ruin my
structure
you might take there i might get a
weakness or two
on f6 and d6 but
for an exchange i will get the bishop
pair that
should provide me enough play
and this of course leads to very
uncompromising play
and which will eventually lead to an
end game should b5 queen d2 they're
playing
all that casual moves take
sticks knight b3 bishop e6
so black is actually not that worried to
lose upon
duba sort of claims the bishop bear
will compensate for that
and that in the long run
that will be enough as these knights are
a little bit clumsy on c3 and b3
so queen takes d6 was played by
dominguez
queen b6 between c5 f5
so this is actually the idea of dubose
concept
he is willing to give and part with a
few and a couple of pawns
for activity
queen takes a b ef
bishop f5 knight d4 and this is again a
critical point
how does black react to these
threats does he take does he do
something else but
if you just ask dubo if you know he is
going to keep those bishops
because that's the heart and soul if uh
he loses the bishop pair he's just
probably going to be down upon for not
much
ship d7 a3
rookie 8 and this is kind of modern
chess
that some might not be used to seeing
black is not unhappy with being down
upon
but with the bishop pair now if you're a
big expert on openings you might notice
similarities between this
and the martial end games where again
you have two bishops
but down a pawn and usually it is a
decent end game
for the black player it does seem like
the same thing here
black has ample compensation not at all
winning
of course but there is an imbalance
going
on so if both sides are ambitious
anything can happen as it did in this
game
rook d3 and talking about imbalances
it's one thing to have bishop versus
two knights with an extra pawn but you
still have to find the right moves and
ideas
the first question i'm sort of asking is
which side we should be playing
naturally we don't tend to want to play
on the
queen side because we have only two
pawns versus three
and it's just not what we would be
looking for
in fact that's not what duda not not
duda that is
not what dubaf does here he actually
plays h5
he says okay it might not be apparent
just yet
what i'm doing with h5 but you'll see
once i get to push my pawn down the
board
that might actually become an asset
rook d1 rook c8 over defending that pawn
so this bishop can freely move once this
knight moves off from d4
f3 c5
c5 chasing that knight away
and sort of preparing this bishop f5
idea
once the knight jumps knight b5
actually he doesn't do so probably
because he didn't like these knight d6
ideas
so he takes her takes here check
here and rookie two and now we get these
typical
unbalanced end games
black has a very active rook
and a bishop very well
placed on h6 stopping any rook d2 ideas
and might help out
if push comes to shove and if there's a
b-pawn rolling down the board
and now you can see the point of h5 this
pawn
will be useful in the ending and
i would definitely say this might just
prove
very much crucial at the
late count
rook g1 just defending the pawn
bishop e3 rook h1
these are not awe inspiring moves by
dominguez
but probably he was not feeling too
confident
with his chances if he gives up the g2
pawn
rookie 8 knight d6
rookie 6 knight e4 just trying to bring
the knight back and
sort of smoke out that rook so you can
take on g2
you will lose your bishop on e3 f5
again typical duboff move he goes
forward
um whatever happens happens it of course
is justified he wants to win the g2 pawn
but it comes at a price of weakening
that structure
knight c3 rook g2 rook e1
f4 and look how the situation has
changed
from a very organized dominguez with
play on the d
file and knight on b5 um
black actually was sort of pushed back
in that case
now it's a role reversal this rook on g2
is strong
plenty of weaknesses on f3 and h2 and
this h pawn
is roaming down and might be the one
cleaning on this square
so knight d5 king f7
bringing in the king knight takes e3
f takes rook takes takes
takes rook takes h2 and for the
initiated
you'd feel that this is nothing special
but a uh do above has
the pawn already on h5 while white
really doesn't have a single pawn on the
fourth and it's also ready to be pushed
to the
fourth and third very close only two
moves away from
queening and there is also a big
difference between this king and this
king stuck
on b1 that king is really not
participating
and with the difference between the
rook's kings
this is a very advantageous end game for
duboff and now you can kind of tell that
these
little differences between these elite
players show
it shows that duboff just has a better
foresight or
at least he had a better foresight in
the preliminaries
he sort of anticipated that if
events kind of die down and they get an
end game he will get better chances
now in the previous example between
shanklin and dubo
it was a two-end throw battle
but in this case you can see that
dominguez couldn't quite clarify the
position
because with every exchange his position
just got worse
b4 takes a takes
rook f2 fixing this rook on e3
it can never move again because you lose
the f-bomb
and the h-bond will make or run for it
now the biggest problem for dominguez is
that after c4
black can go h4 and the aforementioned
problem of that king being on this
square
on b1 just shows because after
palm push takes takes h3
h2 threatens with promotion
with mate so that is a big threat
and it's very uncomfortable to meet with
white
so he goes king b2 trying to avoid that
h4 b5 h3
and now you can see that that earlier
move
of h5 actually comes into play the pawn
is
only two moves away from actually
promoting
well white is nowhere near close to
promoting himself
f4 h2 one move away
and white is still way behind
rook h3 king f6
rook h4 so dominus is sort of trying to
build a blockade
but he is just not in time
he tries to sort of
stop black from getting and coming
forward
because if you go king f5 rook takes f4
this rook takes h2
but in rook and games it's not really
the quantity of the pawns that matter
but the quality of it all
so he goes g5 and says if i could just
get my king to g2
i am going to win this game cleanly
rook h6 king f5 takes stakes
again note you do not have time to take
that pawn
because i just queen rook 87
king g4 and here you can see
the unfortunate placement of this king
kind of
kills all counter play that dominguez
would have
if you go here there's this typical
operation of rook f3 check rook h3
and the promotion is incoming there's
just nothing you can do about it
so there's just no way to go forward
with the king and the pawn and
dominguez is just relegated to move this
rook around but that's not gonna save
the game
okay six king g3
check king f3 check
king g2 and now we get into
the bridge building part of the game
check here rook 86 king g1
and dominguez resigned because there's
absolutely no
counter play anymore there's promotion
coming
and even if you start hoping to
move forward here
black can just cut you off with this
rook f5 move
there's no way forward the king will
just bolt
into the center and it's just game over
it's a very clean win by dubov
not at all easy to win a game like this
especially at this high level but it was
kind of inspiring to see
that he sort of built it all up
for the end game and was even willing to
take some risks
to get into this situation talking about
risks
the third game i'm going to show you is
between
so and duda so in this match
situation duda was leading
in their match so wesley
had to win so now we're going to see
how a super grand master tries to
win a slightly slightly better end game
that looks
minuscule but then he still manages to
win
so let's start from the opening um
wesley was playing white and duda was
black
b3 pusher b2 c5
takes and he takes d5 quite a brave
choice
by duda but he's kind of claiming that
yes
i will have an isolated pawn on d5 but
is a weakness i can tolerate and it
won't be enough for you to win
and that'll be sort of the debate
between wesley
whether that's just slightly better for
white or actually is winnable
for wesley d4 of course you've got to
isolate the d5 pawn bishop e2
d takes c5n we get this famous structure
and actually it does seem to me
it's kind of 50 50. sometimes the
defenders do
defend successfully and in fact duda was
very close
to be successful on other times
the attacker just finds too many targets
and then he just wins
let's see how this plays out green a5
rook c1
ship f6 knight d4 knight takes c5
takes takes so it's not strictly
speaking
and isolated pawn structure anymore it's
more like a hanging pawn
but even in this case we could argue
that these pawns are more of weaknesses
than
strengths or vices for the position
knight e4 queen c2
um takes takes
takes takes queen takes a2
looks like it's losing a queen but not
really because
that bishop is hanging and duda spots
that obviously
rook c2 queen a3 rk1
and we are almost at the end game part
it's not quite yet an end game but
it feels like a middle game that's
closer to an end game
than like a regular middle game you're
used to this is
very much unlike a dragon position
so bishop e6 over defending the d pawn
rook d2 queen b4 so
there are different objectives for the
sides
wesley so's objective is to keep as many
pieces on the board as possible
because in that case this king can
become vulnerable
and that could be an extra added target
for black for uh krishna
he's actually hoping to somehow exchange
off the a pawn for the b-pawn
if that happens even if he loses the
d-pawn
that might just lead to a very
well-known drawn engine
rook d3 book fc8
queen a6 h6 very reasonable choice
just creating a loft for the king h3
rook c3 aiming for what i said
he's trying to somehow win the b pawn
because if he can do so
he's more than likely to be drawing
queen a3
so you can see that
that's wesley is trying to get into the
end game without having that exchange
happen
take sticks rook takes d3 takes
king f8 king f1
rook b8 king e2 rugby seven
so i would say that both sides sort of
achieved their objective
black achieved the objective of
actually having a close to even position
and white has achieved the objective of
having an advantage looking like a draw
but
not quite a draw yet and this is what i
would
call maybe 50 50 is a bit optimistic
you could maybe argue that it's easier
for white to play this position
because a couple of slips can ruin
dudas chances as we shall see
king d2 king e7
now the second objective for vesty will
be to push this b
pawn up so there is no hope of ever
exchanging the pawn
and also sort of pushing black back
king c3 bringing the king up check
king d4 centralizing
something that's very important in
rook and pawn endings rook b7
king c5 trying to come closer to the a
pawn
check king here
bishop a6 now you might be wondering
again
why did wesley repeat there that is the
typical probing way of playing these
positions
you're sort of wondering if your
opponent will defend
accurately and you're sort of nudging
them
hey hey are you okay do you know what
you're doing
and so far duda is showing no
signs of giving up rook c7
trying to get counter play but of course
that's not going to happen the rook is
just going to take away that square
we should have five and here comes this
maneuver we talked about
he's getting and pushing that b-pawn
forward now also bishop a6 was a nice
touch
by wesley he's taking away this active
square from the rook
and the stroke is somewhat without
targets it does defend the a7 pawn
but apart from defending it doesn't
really do much
bishop e6 objective done
i could push the pawn to b4 now i'll go
back
as b5 will be on the cards rook b7
b5 so plenty of objectives
has been done so far by wesley he got
the king activated
he got the pawn to b5 this is a
potential target
d5 is a potential target so essentially
he has
everything to win this position does
that mean it's
lost for duda definitely not
any time what would get aggressive that
would give
some counter chances for duda
bishop d7 notice he is immediately going
for these
strategies now if you take on d5 there's
bishop b5
and this is what i've been talking about
even
if you somehow win the a pawn this is
considered very drawish
i mean black might not even lose it yet
but even if you lose it it is probably
more likely to be a draw than
not but he goes rook a5 of course
he's not going to exchange it off he
wants
to keep the b pawn bishop e6
f4 so objective has been accomplished on
the queen side so he's looking
for other and new weaknesses on
the king side f6
g4 rook c7
or k6 again rook a6
isn't necessarily the best move but it's
probing
saying are you going to tolerate the
presence of my rook
and of course dude that's saying no i'm
not going to tolerate the presence of
that rook
okay 5 here rook a6
here rook a4 so he keeps
repeating but he
sort of slowly improves his pieces
so you notice he's not putting it back
to e5 but a4
and he claims that okay i made a slight
adjustment here so there's something
there's a new thread that you will have
to
look out for bishop e6
bishop e2 not yet a threat
but it is a hint of a thread of bishop
f3
kingd6 you're going back
king e7 rook a4 king d6
f5 so 1
step forward two steps back
and slowly he's actually going to roll
forward
now he's making another step forward
push
f7 rk6 king e7 bishop d1
and these mysterious moves actually make
a lot of sense
because it kind of trips up
duda because not only does
vesti threaten bishop b3 but he also
threatens ideas of bishop f3
and it's very difficult to keep up with
this in a practical
game you might think or notice with a
computer that okay this is holdable
but it's very unpleasant to face because
the threats of wesley is so ambiguous
rook c4 here rook c7
but so far duda is very patient
he's not reacting too much and he's just
waiting for wesley to show his hands
and he can do that because any time
wesley goes for a clear-cut plan
that will expose a target let's say on
b5
or sometimes some weaknesses on the
other side
king d4 check
here bishop e2 and again this is a bit
of a psychological warfare
what is sort of hinting oh you're very
close to the draw
you're very close to repetition but
you're never really going to get it
king d7 king d4
king e7 h4
again slightly improving on the position
hinting at a potential g5 or h5
fixing this g7 pawn and in that case
there'll be
one two and three weaknesses if we add
up the g
pawn king d7
duda is not budging
bishop d1 here back
bishop b3 now he makes this move
king e7 here
rook b7 rook a5 of course
uh wesley is not going to give up on the
b pawn rook d7
rook b7 oh not rook c7
because that would leave this pawn
hanging but rook b7 again trying to take
that
king c5 and this is the moment
i feel that duda got a little bit
tired of reacting because most of the
things that he's been doing so far
for like 20 30 moves is just reacting
to wesley's threats and he sort of gives
up on that idea
he definitely should have checked here
and just wondered
what are you going to do if i chase your
king away
but he sort of got tired of that and
played rook d7
rk5 check
king d4 here bishop a2
but now it's a different scenario
and there is a difference between this
position
with the rook on a6 and the rook on a5
with the rook on a6 black had this idea
of root b7
and then going back now you can go rook
b7
because of bishop takes d5 here then e4
and
white is very close to be winning
because black is just too passive
and down a pawn
so here wesley sort of outsmarted
his young polish opponent who's a big
talent of course
in his own right now the rook on a5 is
actually defending the pawn
and black is running out of moves you
can't move the rook
you lose the d-pawn you can't move
anything on
d6 and d8 you lose the a7 pawn so zeus
long
is very much the name of the game king
d8
king c5 book c7
back okay six but notice
the king moved so even if we have
any sort of exchanges the king might
just bolt in there
at some good moment king e7
rook c6 rook b7
here they're just repeating once more
h5 again sort of
keeping duda under wraps
and constant pressure so if you ask me
this sort of reminds me more of a boxing
match
than a chess match and
duda just never gets enough time
to get out of trouble he's under
pressure
constantly being asked questions
and there's no bell to save him king d8
rook c5 and now the pawn falls
and that means only bad things for duda
king e7 takes
takes king takes d5 and as we talked
about
earlier there's just too much difference
between the activity of pieces
white has an amazing king on d5 a great
rook on c5
and the polish player just has
two passive pieces now he sort of missed
his boat
of being a little bit more aggressive
earlier on
king d7 king c4 moving around
going after the a pawn rook b6
but he checks now just asking the
question
are you going to go this way well then i
can go and play on this side of the
board if you move this way
i might just consider going the other
direction king c7
can see picking c5 rook b8
e4 a very natural decision
wesley is trying to get closer to the g
pawn rook b6 e5
takes takes king d7 rook e6
and that's kind of the tragedy of duda's
position
you can't really go into the end game
because white's king is just infinitely
better than blacks
and this b-pawn that vastly kept and
nurtured for so long
is going to win the game so he has to go
rook
b7 but then rook g6 and now it really
curtains
because check king e8 f6
g takes rook takes h6 and with this many
weaknesses
two connected pawns white is just
completely dominating the position here
rook g6
again emphasizing the fact that the end
game is completely one
here rook takes f6 here
king e4 and if the pawn was somewhere on
h7 or g7
or f7 g7 of course would be a bit
ridiculous could take the rook
but let's say f7 or h7 there would be
some drawing chances there but with two
connected pass pawns
this is an easy one for the elite
and mesti of course is an elite player
king e7
rook f5 keeping that king
out of sorts and in that case promoting
the h and g
pawn is just easier check here rook b1
h6 rook h1
g5 the spawns are just too fast rook a5
attacking that pawn and defending that
pawn from the sides
there king g4 king f7
check king g8 here
check this would be checkmate that is
avoided by duda
rook a7 rook b1 and after king h5
he resigned rightfully so because there
is no
escaping this position a very nice game
by wesley slowly building the advantage
and
crashing through in the right moment so
i really hope you enjoyed
these games by do both and wesley
so hope you enjoyed your time goodbye
[Music]
you